OOOOoooo yeas time for some of that prime
time Chainsaw Man, AS in todays video we are
diving back into and completing the 2nd arc to
part 2 of the series, that being the War Devil
Arc! This video follows directly after the end
of Part 2’s introductupion arc where we were
introduced to Asa Mitaka and her new soul mate,
the beautifully arrogant War Devil. Obviously if
you do enjoy content just like this and want to
see more, than make sure to subscribe and leave
a like as it really healps out with pushing
my content to a bunch of new amazing people!
PLUS FAT CHAINSAW MAN GIVE AWAY IN THIS VIDEO!
More on that in a few minutes so stay tunned!
So as we start back out we find people
celebrating and walking around in that
top tier chainsaw man merch, various citizens are
interviewed by a news outlet about Chainsaw Man,
its pretty 50/50 in regards to what the think
about him. Some extremely are enthusiastic about
him where as on the other hand other people
doubt his intentions, giving reasons such as
getting rid of jobs for Demon Hunters,
claiming that he's an American psyop,
that he's too destructive, that he's too
popular, or that he eats people and pets.
Denji who just happens to be among the citizens
being interviewed attempts to make Chainsaw Man
look better, dude literally goes on a full tangent
about how, frankly its not possibly chainsaw man
ate the cat, that everybody at his school loves
him and that he bets he’s a seriously great guy…
Yet instantly the film crew turn around and are
like yeah lets cut that he spoke far to much.
As the crowd now goes back to screaming our
boys name, nobody actually recognizes he is
who they are talking about, but still Denji
stands there proud like the legend he is.
Everyone's favorite 25 year old repeat
highschool student Yoshida then rolls up on
the scene as everybody screams for Chainsaw
Man, but once he tries to speak to Denji,
Denji doesn't seem to recognize him at all (Which
im wondering if he simply forgot who Yoshida
is or if he’s trying to distance himself from
anyone previously at the bureau). After Yoshida
is literally like Ooff bro that hurts, remember
when you had all those assassins after you, Denji
blatantly lies and says that he never remembers it
happening. Following a short awkward conversation,
the duo end up making there way to a café.
Denji order a massive feed and while sitting
there with Yoshida notices that he’s wearing
the same uniform as him. Yoshida blatantly lies,
blowing it off as a coincidence that they attend
the same school. Denji prods further tho and asks
if Yoshida is actually stalking him, to which
he explains that technically he isn't wrong and
infact he belongs to part of an organization. Not
the evil type that you’d usually find in manga,
but instead the group is simply seeking to
protect Denji from having his secret identity
revealed to the public allowing him to live a
peaceful life. Elaborating more he explains,
that pretty much he’ll be in a load of trouble
if Denji’s true identity if revealed once more to
the public. (Kinda like how when all the assassins
showed up during the international assassins arc,
people knew Chainsaw Man was in Japan but
they didnt necessarily know the human face,
just the chainsaw one) Yoshida tells Denji that
if he doesn't listen and his identity is exposed,
he wont allow him to eat anymore cake. Disgusted
with the idea of not being allowed any of life's
luxury’s Denji instead slams his hand down
onto the table cutting the cake with his hand.
While Denji stuffs his gullet, Yoshida is left
utterly flabbergasted with the change in events,
he tries explaining that if he lets the cat
out the bag (using a cat as per usual) the
life he has now will fall to pieces. Confused he
askes why he’s fighting as chainsaw man anyway,
and finally as our boy scoffs down all
of his food he reveals his current goal,
telling Yoshida that he wants his identity to
be revealed because once the secrets out the
ladies will be all over him. Yoshida sits
there for a moment in utter bewilderment
tryna think up a witty reply, but simply
cant deny the fact he’s probably correct.
Skipping away from the horndog, we are flying
over to our neuro divergent queen as Yoru pounds
her fists and screams into a pillow, pissed
off that she and Asa were saved by Chainsaw
Man. (obviously this is cause her goal in this
is to literally take out Chainsaw Man.) Asa asks
why the War Devil wants Chainsaw Man dead so
badly, to which Yoru opens up about how during
her fight with Chainsaw Man alongside the other
Four Horsemen, her body was partially consumed,
weakening her and explaining why there had been
no major wars since The World War (though this
was partially due to Chainsaw Man consuming
the Nuclear Weapons Devil and the World War
II Devil as we learned in the control devil arc).
Yoru also opens up about being worried that since
war has been relegated to just being a media
subject, everyone would soon forget about the
concept or war and she would continue weakening
to the point she would cease to exist. Asa asks
if Yoru is afraid of being forgotten, but quickly
realizes the previously raging Devil had already
fallen asleep. Laying there herself, Asa thinks
that for the longest time she didnt care if she
died, but now she's happy she hasn't and thanks
Chainsaw Man for saving her before falling asleep.
The next day and OML DENJI I MEAN FUJIMOTO
U HAVE TO CHILL, THIS SOME CRAZY SHIT,
At school Denji absolutely loving life is shown
to be acting as a seat for a young lady, only to
be called away by Yoshida. Denji explains that
for every 10 minutes he pretends to be a chair,
he gets paid ¥10, but if he’s held up
much longer he’ll have to refund her.
Yoshida returns Denji's Student I.D. card,
explaining he dropped it during the fight
with the cockroach devil and he won't let
Chainsaw Man's identity get exposed as he
knows for a fact Denji purposely left it there in
the hope he’d be Identified as the devil itself.
Denji tries to back away so he can
go back to making bank being a chair,
only for Yoshida to turn around and actually pay
him 10,000 YEN if he stays and acts as his seat.
He then asks Denji if he's trying to expose
his identity in order to get a girlfriend,
to which he confirms. Yoshida then offers to find
him a girlfriend if he promises not to expose his
identity to the public and Denji is instantly like
OKAY introduce me to her. Yoshida quickly asks,
what his type is and Denji in the most down bad
statement i've ever read explains that his type
is "a girl who's desperate for a boyfriend."
AND YOSHIDA BEING ON THE SAME MENTAL PLANE AS
MYSELF INSTANTLY REALISES HE KNOWS THE PERFECT
GIRL WHO SEEMINGLY FITS THAT EXACT DESCRIPTION.
Flashing outside, probably to the top of the
school where Asa usually hangs out. There Yoshida
brings up that Asa was saved by Chainsaw Man and
introduces Denji as a huge fan of the Chainsaw
Man who’d love to talk to her. Asa explains that
she used to hate Chainsaw Man, bringing up several
reasons as to why, with Denji refuting each claim
every time with an increasing frustration. Asa
claims that Denji wouldn't know what Chainsaw Man
is like as its not like he could possibly be him.
Again she continues dogging on the chainsaw man
with Denji eventually getting to the point where
he boils over and confesses that he knows all of
this information because he is indeed the Chainsaw
Man. Continuing to brag about knowing exactly
what Chainsaw Man is thinking because he is him,
he asks her if she gets it now. Not believing him
in the slightest though and with Yoshida literally
facepalming, Asa calls him a loser and instantly
leaves, to which as Denji screams after her,
Yoshida remarks that nobody would believe
him if he continued acting so flagrantly.
BEFORE WE GO ANY FUTHER, FAT CHAINSAW MAN MANGA
GIVE AWAY INCOMING! YOU SEE THESE CHAINSAW MAN
VOLUMES 3, 10 and 11. WELL I ACCIDENTALLY
BOUGHT DOUBLE UPS! IF YOU WANNA GET THE
CHANCE TO WIN THESE THAN LEAVE A COMMENT DOWN
BELOW WITH YOUR FAVOURITE MOMENT THROUGHOUT
THE SERIES AND TWITTER TAG SO I CAN FOLLOW
YOU BACK IF YOU WIN. Ill just use a random
comment picker to pick the winner so man sure
to include your @ ANYWAYS BACK TO THE VIDEO!
Having left Denji on the roof, Yoru is
enraged that she didn't outright merc
Denji for admitting to being Chainsaw
Man. Asa on the other hand who straight
up calls Yoru an idiot for actually
believing that him is still unconvinced,
explaining how it makes no sense for him to be
a mega-fan as well as the actual Chainsaw Man.
Later on an after school ends for the day, Yoru
demands that Asa hunts for another devil in order
to get into the devil hunter club, though she says
that she's going to visit Yuko instead. Enraged,
Yoru threatens her and asks if she’s
even thought of a way to find Chainsaw
Man. Asa retorts (btw I wonder if people
realize she’s literally talking aloud to
no one haha Anyways) She states that
if they lead a devil to the school,
he would reveal himself anyway. Wondering
how to actually draw a Devil to school,
Asa plays to Wars arrogant side, calling her the
smart one and leaving her with the planning while
she visits Yuko! Watching her walk away, Yuro
thinks that perhaps she really can tame her.
Once arriving at Yoku’s house and after being
surpirsed for praised by her friend, they sit
with each other telling secrets; Yuko admits to
reading self-help books on how to make friends,
whilst Asa confesses that she wet herself during
class one day, which causes Yuko to literally curl
over in her seat laughing about how the class
played along to Asa’s terrible sweat excuse!
Yuko then in a complete change of direction
confesses that she actually took out her
neighbour for gambling away his welfare payments,
yet unable to even form a proper sentence,
Asa just keeps repeating what the hell in a
non-chalant manner. However after one of Yuko’s
other neighbour's say high, she even offers
to show Asa where the deceased man is now.
Asking if shes joking, yuko simply replies
that its out back if she wants to see,
but Asa wisely declines. LIKE HOLY I WOULD
BE FREAKING OUT IF THIS WAS GOING ON IRL,
CHOOSE YA FRIENDS WISELY PEOPLE! Anyways,
saying that its fine eitherway, as they
are best friends because they revealed each
others closest secrets Yuko promises her that
she wont tell anyone about how she peed
herself, or about she took out the teacher,
class president and has made a contract
with the devil inside of her named Yoru!
Stating that there’s no secrets between the two,
Yuko then reveals that she also made a
deal with the Justice Devil yesterday,
granting her the ability to read minds in
order to be able to understand those around
her as she doesn't get people! Then on top of
that she reveals that its also to help Asa,
and as they are now besties, Yuko decides
she will "handle" her bffs bullying problem.
Later on while walking through the
streets, Yoru and Asa talk about Yoku
being a devil. They talk about how Yoku
going to solve Asa’s bullying problem at
school, but she just doesnt know what she
meant by warning her not to go! Telling her
to stop the stupidness, Yoru explains that she is
obviously going to take out all of classmates that
bully her. Asa puts forward the idea of talking
Yoku out of it but Yoru disagrees, asking her,
how she's going to go about doing that! WHEN HER
BODY ALREADY BELONGS TO HER! Yoru instead plans
on destroying Yoku as soon as she reaches school.
Asa is shocked and strongly disagrees. However,
according to Yoru, this would lead
Chainsaw Man straight to them and
even if it doesnt it would get them into the
devil hunters club through taking out Yoku.
Elsewhere Yoku though, that absolute maniac
is seen burning something while maniacally
repeating that she’ll save Asa soon and
get rid of all the bad guys for her.
Moving into the next day, Yoku who
woke up slightly late greets people
on her possibly final journey to school…
Yet as you all probably saw coming,
as she made her through the schools hallway she
is confronted by no one other than the War Devil.
Trying to buy time through talking,
Yuko brings up how its weid that chainsaw
man goes to this school, as it doesnt
even prevent bullying. Then she considers
that perhaps he only fights other devils.
Putting that thought aside for now, Yoku
says they can fight once she gets rid of
the bullies. Obviously, Yoru doesn’t agree
as she thinks Yoku will run as soon as she’s
finished her job. Yoku says, “You can’t
beat me if we fight anyways as I can read
your every move.” Inciting the battle to
being though, Yoru asks Yoku to beat her,
but reminds her that Asa will be taken out as
well. Frustrated as she loves Asa but hates
Yoru more than anything, Yoku ultimately
decides to transform into her devil form.
Instantly, Yuko shoots out a bunch of limbs
into the tight hallway, Yoru dodges between
the flying projectiles manages to get of a few
attacks with a pencil she turned into a blade.
Taking a bita damage Yuko yells “Cool, but you’re
in my way” and goes on to hit Yoru as she floats
in the air. Having been sent shooting back,
Yoru lands in a classroom and panic instantly
ensues as the students yell and run for their
lives. Catching a glimpse of the Devil, a random
teacher makes an emergency announcement stating
that A dangerous Devil has appeared on campus,
urging students to escape
thru the nearest escape route.
During the panic some students are seen
questioning whether this is a drill or no.
Well those eggs are utterly stunned as the
devil itself appears behind them and says,
“This is not and drill”. Turning the students
exclaim and run for their lives all the while the
devil walks behind them asking who put chucking in
the locker the other day. Once spotting the girls,
Yoru suddenly appears from behind and throws a
pencil which morphs into spear. But sadly the
devil but she blocks it and says that she
told her that she can read her every move!
Yoku goes on to throw the spear directly into
one of the students trying to flee and knocks
down another one smashing her against the
wall. Fortunately, while she is looking for
the last student, a devil hunter appears.
The hunter introduces himself as Seigi from
the Devil hunter club and says that he’ll buy
time till the real hunters arrive. (poor dude
doesn't know what he just got into). Yoku yells
that she doesn’t want to hurt innocent randoms
but proceeds to attack him either way. Luckily
it turns out this boy is a damn prodigy and he
showcases some slick moves being able to smash
yuko in the stomach. Running up behind his boy,
Furio arrives instantly aiming and shooting
his crossbow at the beast in front of him.
While the three fight Yoku, a female hunter
from the schools club dives in and decapitates
one of the monsters horns. With three baby
hunters and Yoru beating down on the Devil,
she talks abit of smack asking her if she was
gonna die before chainsaw man even got here? Yoku
who obviously wasnt trying to hurt the innocent,
tsays that since they have ganged up on her,
she has no other choice. Sadly she proceeds
to slam them all with her orbiting limbs,
seemingly taking out the 3 wanna be hunters. She
then goes on to warn Yoru that she’ll end up like
them as she knows how Yoru has laid traps for her
and set up various weapons throughout the school.
She says that she is going to save
Asa from her bullies, Yoru replies,
that she has one more idea though,
before giving her body back to Asa,
who as you’d imagine goes on to
plead with Yoku asking her to stop.
Confronting the Justice
Devil, Asa to reason with her,
but Yoku states that she has only
taken out all of the bad ones,
according to her this will serve as a lesson
to all the bullies in Japan and end bullying
altogether. Asa snaps at this though and asks
Yoru to instruct her about how to make a weapon
to which she explains that she needs to touch
something that belongs to her and call its name.
Yoku yells that there is no point to it but Asa
goes on to tear off her uniform and say “Super
Strong Uniform Sword!”. As a result her uniform
tears off from around her and transforms to a huge
rectangular sword, leaving Asa standing there in
her bathing suit. Apart from showing off her well
maintained body, she goes on to threaten Yoku and
gives her a final warning. Yoku goes on to explain
to her this ‘eradicating bullies plan’ and that
how she is trying to become a symbol of justice,
like Chainsaw Man. Asa says that it all makes no
sense and asks what she gave up in exchange for
the devils powers, but Yoku simply replied that
there was no giving. Instead they only received.
Yoku says that when she was given this power she
was also given a heart that shines with the light
of justice along with it. After saying this she
moves on to kill the final bully and asks Asa to
put on some clothes, passing her off as a simple
nuisance she doesn't have the time for. Asa runs
forward and tries to cut of the Devils leg, but
Yoku easily whacks the sword out of her hand.
Watching this, Yoru mocks her, calling her weak
while Yoku simultaneously mocks, HOWEVER before
she could finish her sentence, she’s all of a
sudden cut into a few hundred sushi sized pieces.
Yes SURPRISINGLY Asa was the one who took her down
without with the sword she created from her damn
school uniform. Its explained that the reason he
weapon was randomly broken in terms of strength
is because her mom gave her that uniform before
she died! Man Tatsuki always out here blowing my
puny monkey mind with these god tear weapons the
war devil can create or just the swords in general
created by Devils thougout the series,
they are all just so well done. Anyways
Obviously Asa didn't want to have to do this
and is just heartbroken over what happened,
urging what remains of the justice devil
to live on. Suddenly a mysterious girl
arrives asking if she wants to save her.
Obviously, Asa replies affirmatively and
the girl looking down on her revealing her
also spiral eyes states “Anything… For my
little sister”. Asa is shocked to hear this
while at the same time Devil hunters arrive
on the scene asking the public where the devil
is. HOWEVER there aint no need to try and find
her as all of a sudden the building explodes
with the now oversized revived Justice Devil…
Yoku now resurrected takes a moment to
remember what she was up to and then
continues her rampage completely destroying a
few levels of the school with a massive lashing
attack. Two boys attack her from behind
but she taunts them and easily defeats the
both of them.. Suddenly though she stops and
see’s Asa lying on the ground, badly wounded.
Freaking out about who did this, she picks up a
random girl, blames her and is about to crush her
before being stopped by the legend himself, Denji
who’s just showed up on the block. Looking over,
she asks him to mind his own business, but
Denji who’s trying to not blow his cover
realizes that a SUPERHERO cant stand round idly
during an emergency! Screaming at him to leave,
Yoku swings at him, yet out boys got that
speed now and quickly manages to dodge the
strike before transforming and slicing the
Justice devils arm open. Screaming again,
but this time in pure fear, Yoru is
surprised and yells at him to stay
away while sending a plethora of
expanding limbs in his direction.
Denji yells that Chainsaw Mans here to save
the day and dives down, dodging all of her
strikes. Stumped on why she cant land an
attack, Yoku tries to read his mind but
its completely perplexed after learning that
Denji isn't even thinking about the damn fight,
instead man is solely focused on how to
expose his own identity as the Chainsaw
Man while making it seem natural. As we float
there above the two fighting devils, it shoots
away over to a beaten Asa waking up after being
knocked out. Standing up, Yoru’s personality
takes a hold as she see’s chainsaw man
now standing directly in front of her!
Asa picks up Yuko’s leg and yells “Yoku
Leg Sword” creating a damn sword out of
her leg before asking Chainsaw Man if
he remembers her. (Obviously she doesnt
realize its Denji I dont think) Our boy,
being the perv he is, looks at her body,
and then her bottom. Anyways, then randomly
the girl Denji had just saved rises out of
the devil body. Randomly the girl starts
freaking out thinking he’s going to eat her
but Denji clarifies that he saves people,
not eat them as he is human on the inside.
Suddenly, Asa leaps into action and is about
to hit Chainsaw Man but she once she swings,
hits nothing and finds out that he vanished.
She gets infuriated not being able to find
him and she thinks Chainsaw Man doesn’t deem her
worthy, yet in actuality, Denji was cucked out of
a reveal by Yoshida’s tentacles so fast that
Yoru didn’t even realize what happened. Over
with Octoboy, Yoshida tells Denji he’s hopeless
and that he’d stop him by force if he had to.
Now in a differnt turn of events, we find
Asa running down an alleyway littered with
dead chickens, so many chickens in fact that
she can’t help herself to not step on them.
Then running into the darkness thats infront
of her she wakes back up in a terrified sweat.
Getting up out of bed she grabs a drink
of water and goes to go back to sleep,
but then mysteriously her doorbell rings.
Scared, Asa asks who’s there and the
person outside quickly apologizes
for showing up so late at night.
Asa is about to open the door but the person
yells “Do not open it” and she identifies
herself as Yoku. She says that she managed
to escape but has turned into the devil and
if Asa opens the door, she might try to eat
her. Asa being her divergent self has 0 want
to sustain a normal life and opens the door
anyway revealing Yoku’s new humanoid form.
Haing opened the door Asa asks if she wants to
eat her, to which Yoku says a little bit and
chooses to not look at her to avoid temptation.
She says that she’s here to say goodbye as she
is going to a distant relative who’s a devil
hunter in search of a way to turn her back
to a human. Yoku clarifies that she made the deal
with Justice Devil not to save her but to be like
Chainsaw Man and make people like her. (which
is an extremely intersting form of a contract,
I personally wonder if the wording
in a contract matters) Anyways She
goes on to say that she is the worst and
that everything she did was meaningless.
Asa tries to stop Yoku from walking away but
I'm assuming Justice’s side unknowingly hits
her with her tail. She says she didn’t intent
to hit her and just wanted to give her a proper
goodbye since she was her first friend. She
warns her not to make a deal with the Justice
Devil like her then once again goes to leave, but
Asa stops her and tells her to just wait for one
second. Coming back out, its revealed that like
when they first became friends Asa wants to
hand her over a pair of shoes since she noticed
Yoku was barefoot. Being stubborn Yoku refuses
but Asa says if she doesn’t need them, so
she can sell them and if they won’t sell,
she can just throw them away. Yoku laughs
a little realizing that she was the one who
first said that super cringe like.. Instantly
they both crack up laughing at how dumb they
sounded. Yet still out girl has a realization and
can see that she truly is the worst, everything
that she's done has caused people a load of
pain and here she is now, laughing about it..
After sharing that sweet moment together Asa
tells her that she better bring those shoes
back some day, to which Yoku promises her
she will! AHH BUT THIS IS CHAINSAW MAN NOT
MHA and as Yoku is jumping from building
to building wishing she could read birds
minds some pigeons wondering if she could read
their minds as well. We hear the suspicious noise
of a chainsaw BUT see Asa being slightly restless
in bed, as Denji also sleeps soundly with Nayuta.
YET somehow Yoku has been completely destroyed
by something that must resemble the Chainsaw Man,
as someone with a similar figure stands atop the
skyscraper holding onto the ankle of Yuko’s leg.
SOOO Skipping forward a few days I would imagine
to the moment they can return to school which is
in a bad shape and under repair as it was almost
completely destroyed. Asa suddenly remembers the
mysterious girl who called her “my little
sister” and asks Yoru if she was her sister
but Yoru denies calling the mysterious girl
“a mad-woman” (WHICH IS JUST THE WORST LIE
IVE SEEN FROM HER SO FAR, ANYWAYS). Thinking
internally Asa assumes that she brought back
Yoku and wonders if the girl was the real
Justice Devil. Walking through the school,
she encounters the devil-hunters club which
fought Yoku and lost a bunch of its members..
Instantly she notices the mysterious girl she was
talking about as a part of this club. The council
president though, who looks like a fighter out
of DIG FIGHT ISLAND introduces himself as “Haruka
Iseumi” and says that the devil hunters club
lost 2 members the other day during the conflict.
Yet, he says that Akoku (that initial dude
who showed up and stunted on the Justice
Devil ANYWAYSS) He told him how well Asa fought
in the conflict and offers her a spot in the
club. Momintarily Yoru takes control, saying
that she heard Chainsaw Man was a member of
the club and if Haruka knew him. Confidently
then laughs and goes on to reveal his chest
which has the same pull starter as Denji,
therefore, revealing himself as the Chainsaw
Man. Of course we know he is an imposter and
also that he most likely was the person atop
the building with Yoku. She gets furious and
leaves saying, “See you around, Chainsaw Man”.
Asa asks Yoru if that guy really is Chainsaw
Man and Yoru replies that the starter proves it.
Asa wonders why he outed himself like that and
also why Yoru also didn’t lash out to fight him.
Yoru said she could barely beat Yoku by herself,
so there is no way she can go up against Chainsaw
Man currently and win. Yoru says she needs
a strong weapon and commands Asa to conjure
a weapon even stronger than her Uniform Sword
or she’ll merc her. Asa agrees saying she’ll
make her the strongest weapon ever and beat
Chainsaw Man, to which Yoru replies that she’s
randomly obedient today. Asa knows tho that the
sooner she is done with him, the sooner she’ll
leave her because as long as Yoru inhabits her
body everyone around her will be miserable!
Asa says she’ll do anything to make that happen
and even turn “someone” into weapon. She starts
looking at people on the busy street below her
while Yoru says she doesn’t have to turn use a
human as if she has something more important to
her than that will work. Suddenly a cat walks
in (WHICH IS LIKE NAHHH DUDE) and Yoru suggests
to turn it into a weapon. Asa says she’s rather
use a human than a cat and instead starts looking
for a criminal or some other low life. Yoru says
that won’t work as creating a powerful weapon
requires a powerful guilt, instead she suggests
that she pick someone between cat and criminal.
Looking down at all the humans below her,
she suddenly sees Denji who looks like the biggest
dweeb there PLUS on top of that dude is literally
picking up rubbish off the street. Asa thinks
that he is a loser and an idiot but still a
good person. She observes further and finds out
that he is rolling new cigarettes out of these
butts and then selling them to homeless people
for a high price claiming them to be American
premium. Having a change of heart, Asa thinks he
is a bad person trying to rip off the homeless,
but not bad enough to deserve death. Basically
he is what she's looking for, Yoru confirms this
saying he’s the right choice, use him to defeat
Chainsaw Man and get her body back. While thinking
about Yoku, Yoru tells her to think of it as
necessary evil to put an end to a nightmare.
Having caught up and found Denji, They have
a short conversation as Denji recognizes her
as the girl who doesn’t like Chainsaw Man.
He says he is really busy and doesn’t have
time to talk but Asa asks if he’s free
tomorrow. Saying that he’s busy the next
day though, Denji turns her down, but as we know
our dude is a sucker for melons and on a second
look asks her why she asked. To which while she
blushes like crazy, she awkwardly asks Denji for a
DATE. Ahhh Man who probably just had fireworks go
off inside of his brain simply replies with yes!
Skipping forward to the day and looking hella
cute, Asa is seen preparing for her date while
Yoru chills in the corner repeatedly mocking
hers. She doubts she’ll be able to seduce him
and turn him into a weapon, but Asa says its
easy as boys fall for anyone who’d even show
them a fraction of good time. She says Yoru
won’t understand as she’s a Devil and that Asa
believes she is pretty darn cute, cute enough
to make Denji fall head over heals for her.
Out on the date with the Duo at the aquarium,
Asa continuously talks about the various kinds
of fish there while Denji listens. However our
boys a monkey brain and gets frustrated with
all the info, asking her to stop so they
can move on and see those Penguins! Asa is
defiantly somewhat neuro divergent and denies him
saying that she has planned their date properly,
to the point they’ll have to wait here
for at least another 10 minutes. Denji
who’s completely shocked with her dominating
attitude gives in and now Asa stars talking in
length about Starfish. Our boy once again gets
frustrated and asks her visit Penguins now,
yet once again Asa repeats the same thing as
before and says Denji will have to listen about
Starfish for at least another 30 minutes. As she
continues explaining starfish, she think Denji
should be falling for her by now. Cutting in on
her, Denji pleads with her wanting to see those
BEAUTIFUL PENGUINS! And as youd imagine, she
tries to make him stick with her fun plan but
he disagrees and says he’ll experience it his own
way, storming off to see those illusive penguins.
Blown away with the turn of events, Asa just cant
understand why, but Yoru once again taunts her and
says that maybe its because she’s a total bore
and that not only Denji but even she was bored
the entire time Asa was lecturing. Asa ends up
yelling at the devil exclaiming that she is right,
that she studied up for ages on all
of these facts and these silly ass
devils are the real bores. Yoru actually
gives in and asks her to go after Denji,
but Asa who cant stop raging screams she did
everything right. Suddenly someone appears
telling her that she indeed wasn't wrong at all.
Man this girls drip in the Uniform goes so hard,
and I just realised now u can visibly
see her earing trigger switch. ANYWAYS
The girl says she is right and Denji doesnt
know the first thing about right and wrong!
Menacingly looking at her she states that there
is wrong about one thing which shes wrong about,
she can’t turn Denji into a weapon. She
tells Asa who only does the right thing,
that she cant turn a human into
a weapon. Asa is visibly shocked,
asking the girl how in the world
does she knows about her powers.
Taking off her cap, she introduces herself
as the War Devil’s big sister the INFAMOUS
FAMINE DEVIL! and asks Asa to call her Fami!
(Obviously this is the 3rd of the 4 horsemen
and oml having caught up now we got this so
much earlier than I expected) Anyways! Yoru
asks Asa to not listen to her but suddenly
both Fami and Yoru disappear. Asa exclaims
Yoru’s name but Fami only responds says she has
separated Yoru from her temporarily and that Asa
isn’t leaving the Aquarium un till she abandons
her Morality and converts Denji into a weapon.
Having been walking around unable to find
the Penguins Denji appears and says we’ve
got an emergency. He says that the Aquarium
isn’t that big but he can’t find a way out,
no matter how far he walks.
While Asa gasps, Denji mutters,
“That pain in the butt’s back from hell” as
we see a long hallway seemingly with no end.
PERFECT SPOT TO END THE 2nd ARC of Chainsaw Man
part 2 The War Devil Arc. Obviously there is so
much more we are going to learn with here from
here, but I think a lot of the next arc will
involve either the four horsemen, the famine
devil alone OR maybe this eternity devil arc
in part 2 will be a longer part to this story
and become its own arc like it was at the start.